i remember when it kind of first started
off um a group of us were just out out
to dinner and we
very darkly
you know sort of said who's who's going
to be next and we you know chatted and
came up with a list of about
seven people and within six months all
of them were gone
[Music]
do you see yourself as kind of like one
of the early youtubers
uh i don't i don't really see myself as
an early youtuber i still consider
myself third generation
which means nothing to anyone except me
uh but the kind of the first generation
youtubers were literally the the people
that were on there when the site first
kind of booted up in in 2005. i mean the
most subscribed youtuber at one point
was an
80 something year old british guy
called geriatric 1927. uh like he's a
first generation youtuber and then next
would be um second generation people
kind of coming on showing up at around
about 2006 like amazing phil
um and then i i consider myself third
because i started posting in i think
2007 but
i've been putting stuff on the internet
since 2001 or two i think i was about 11
or 12 and i typed in uh the word stupid
and then com because that's how you'd
browse the internet back then just
randomword.com see what shows up and i
saw my first ever online cartoons and i
immediately went oh this is what i would
want to do for the rest of my life just
in that moment just went yep that's it
that's what i'm gonna do
um and everything was kind of building
towards that but yeah so in about 2008
when youtube rolled out the partner
program which enabled you to make money
i'd already had this kind of
understanding of
these six seven years on the internet
figuring out what people liked so i put
all these things that i thought i
understood together into this little
two-minute cartoon called aston movie
and obviously that failed miserably and
this interview isn't happening so
tell my children i love them
my motivation was never
uh financial at least at that stage now
everything is driven by money oh my god
i have a mortgage uh but no at that
point it was just oh neat oh money cool
because i just turned 18
at the point they rolled it out as well
so you know
even money wasn't too much of a concept
i was just starting university so
um it was just a nice a nice bonus i
signed up to the program and you know
you only got paid once you've made a
hundred dollars um and so you know from
the time i became a partner the first
paycheck i got was still a few months um
to make that first 100 and i remember
getting that check and that being a big
moment but it was only in the sort of
the last months of me being at
university so at the point i'd been a
partner about three years that i was
making
enough money to be like oh okay this is
a thing great brilliant really
convenient because i was finishing uni
and i already had this sort of like
full-time uh revenue stream
did you feel an amount of pressure then
it didn't really change much
pressure-wise because
i
wasn't even considering money real i
guess there was no fear it was all just
so wow this is all just happening so i
was just
throwing myself into it and not worrying
about it you know um and and for this
sort of year after that happened i was
on such a high that i was just churning
out just so many videos that were just
doing really well i mean
videos that were getting a million views
in in sort of 20 24 48 hours which was
more impressive back then um and
yeah just dropping things every every
week or or two and
it was just an absolutely bonkers time i
was i was very very just excited and it
was a lot of fun then and how would you
describe your style back then
american um i would describe my style as
well i'd call it explosive comedy which
was just quite americanized so you did
have a lot of that sort of british
uh dry
wit and sarcasm but then someone would
explode and scream and and stuff so yeah
it was quite heavily inspired by
you know on one hand monty python sure
but then just sort of american
ridiculous loudness
uh yeah my audience was just sort of uh
you know u.s by just
logically there were so many of them uh
and then then the uk and then australia
canada sort of all these
english speaking places i think the next
would be germany which really surprised
me but the germans they love
they love those little cartoons i don't
know why
uh i thought that the whole thing was
that they didn't have a sense of humor i
don't know if that's a reflection on me
actually um but they bloody love them
i remember seeing your kind of stickers
and
t-shirts and stuff like that
quite early on
was merch a thing when you were copying
it or was it something you were thinking
oh i could do this and kind of pushing
out on your own yeah there was
in in sort of earlier youtube there were
so many sort of taboos that
we had to
it it it thanklessly pioneered
as it were like merchandise and
sponsorships because it was considered
selling out people that this term
sellout was you don't really hear it to
be honest anymore
because it's just kind of a given but
you know if a youtuber would suddenly
start releasing t-shirts with with with
their their face or quotes from their
videos oh you're a sellout but i always
figured that selling out was
compromising you know your integrity and
doing something you wouldn't normally do
specifically in the pursuit of fame and
money
so you know if a brand was was giving me
a nice budget and i got to make a huge
uh you know a huge production value
sketch just i had to center around oreos
i didn't see that as selling out i was i
thought that was awesome um because i
got to bring more exciting you know
videos to people and and yeah hey thanks
oreo for you i'm not forcing you to buy
or is just hey oreo paid for this isn't
that cool and people go yeah that is
cool and that was that was great it was
a great uh relationship and um but
yeah there'd be a lot of push back at
the time and a lot of uh
anger towards it um i mean hell there
was a point where putting ads on your
videos would make people angry just just
enabling adverts would get caught you
called a cell out and now yeah people
will start a video say hey check out my
new tour i got some new merch but first
here's 40 seconds about uh hello fresh
uh and also you just watched two
unskippable pre-rolls there's a mid-roll
every two minutes on this video and how
we'll just throw some more ads at the
end as well why not so and that and
people don't get mad about that they
just accept that now and that's
great for us i guess but uh yeah it
wasn't
enviable to be someone trying to
trailblaze that as it were a thankless
task
the first sponsored video i ever got was
was in in 2010 and it was for marmite uh
and it was just some
minor player at an ad agency that had
been given a probably like about 500 000
budget and and tasked with reaching out
to you know what would later be called
influencers
um
and and you know this person reached out
and said oh you do a video for marmite
and i was like okay
how much do you pay in like a hundred
pounds oh yippee uh i was 19. that was
great uh i could buy a whole
some pizzas with that um so
i you know i took on this job and i made
this this this video for um for mama and
there was no contract there were no
agreements there was no oh you have to
say this and uh you can't monetize the
video so i released this video i think
it has something like 20 million views
now and i've had ads on that the whole
time so i got my money back in the end
what are you doing i'm sleeping with
your wife john
yeah you are
um you know incorporating the brand in
the creative way and having fun with it
is still more enjoyable uh than just
knowing you're just kind of being talked
at
when you talk about not getting paid for
brands not wanting to do brands
you seem like you're very sort of
relaxed and quite easygoing about it do
you feel that way
i have a lot of grey hair
um
yeah no it's an act i'm not relaxed at
all i'm extremely stressed all the time
i overthink absolutely everything uh
and but it's fun just to recount it and
laugh about it but no we overthink
absolutely everything to a ridiculous
degree that's why i'm one of the many
creators that has experienced varying
degrees of burnout first time i
experienced burnout was i think in 2009
uh i i tried for about a four month
period to release weekly videos
wow weekly videos
and it was a nightmare it was just too
much i couldn't handle it i mean i had
to be very had no crew or anything it
was just me making videos and stuff but
it was trying to make high production
value comedy sketches and stuff but yeah
that that was the first time i
experienced burnout um and it really
just felt like the end of the world at
the time like i'd failed um the next
time would be
uh
a few years later uh when i just
during that sort of big uk youtuber boom
uh when suddenly there was so many more
eyes on so much more excitement and and
i was making loads of content in quite a
manic just churning at our state um but
that you know
you know like pulling an all-nighter you
you pay the piper eventually and and
uh i became burnt out and
[Music]
yeah that 2013 burnout uh
is going on nine years now
around about 2018 um
i
very much felt like i didn't have
anything more to do or say um that i was
really just scraping the bottom of the
barrel of what i had left to kind of
offered the world content-wise i mean in
2018 i started a series called content
which in itself was
was me just going oh [ __ ] it uh here's
just some stuff and i put together this
music video um
as sort of a a tying off of a stuff
movie uh called the muffin song and in
in that video you know i kind of touched
on themes of of burnout and depression
you know because that's what you want
your little funny cartoon
and
[Music]
yeah i put that out and it got about 30
million views and it was it was well
received but it was it was sort of my
way of saying
i think that's it i think that's all i
have to offer and then tick tock
picked up the video and initially it was
just some people doing these quite uh
cringe uh
what it's called uh
videos um
you know lip syncing to it and then it
was getting memed on a lot
and then that evolved into people
enjoying it unironically and you know
very quickly i think within the year
that song went gold uh and it's well on
its way to going platinum the video has
well over 200 million views i think and
it just suddenly bought me
a whole new lease of relevancy but make
no mistake i've been considering that
borrowed time ever since um you know we
we decided to ride this this wave of
popularity from the muffin song we made
we made a card game called muffin time
and that also did really well and
we just kept making stuff a big and
this for about four years now my
mentality has been i'm just gonna keep
making stuff while i'm allowed to uh
because i did not expect to still be
able to do this um
so it is
you know whereas it used to be this
desperate cling to relevance and and
growth uh it is now more of just a
grateful like oh neat people are still
paying attention you've played around
with lots of different types of video
and content um why is that
i've often described myself as
consistently inconsistent that's just
something that i've kind of told people
to get used to
one thing that i've i saw in internet
even before youtube uh is that you know
a creator will get
massive success with one video and then
just go okay
i will just keep doing that um and this
is something that's with a platform like
tick tock is i think even worse i think
that's you can really see these numbers
you know tick tock will do one thing
that gets the laugh and then they will
just keep doing it again and if they
don't you can just see this like
absolute black and white you know 10
million views in the next video they
don't do it in has a hundred views and
then they do it again there's 10 million
views again and so
it can be brutal but like i
saw that trap before i even started
posting on youtube and i really did not
want to get suckered into it so even
when i made the astor movie uh video and
that did really well i i didn't then
just go okay i'm gonna do two three four
five i mean i did do those but i made
sure to put a year between them um and
and in between them i would put out
other things you know longer cartoons
and and comedy sketches and even at some
points short films and and stuff because
i really wanted to just make a lot of
different stuff and and if i wanted an
audience there i wanted them to
um
just enjoy
a variety of things weirdly the most fun
i have these days is doing sponsor
segments for brands because i get to
really just cut loose and make the
wackiest stuff uh and
the pressure isn't nearly as high as it
is
anywhere else uh but don't get me wrong
as soon as uh
as soon as it dries up i'm out of london
i'm gone i'm going home i'm gonna settle
down
get some more dogs
people know about comments online was
that something that affected you on or
something that you could kind of take in
your stride oh yeah it was bad it was
really bad um i was extremely
susceptible to comments i mean the way
it's kind of always worked uh for
a lot of creators i think is that you
know that one negative comment outweighs
a hundred positive ones uh my theory is
always that it's basically
it's because you agree with that
negative comment more they're just
confirming your own insecurities but
yeah no the comments have always been
a thing although weirdly they're fine
now um i think that uh
because i've just been around so long
there's there's not that kind of
excitement no one feels a need to tear
me down but when i was younger and and
more enthusiastic and um and
popular to be honest um there's just
this sort of natural need to tear that
person down and i'll still have that if
i have a video that suddenly does really
well and leaves my sort of bubble of my
audience you'll you'll suddenly start
getting an influx of nasty comments
that's actually the best way to tell
that the video is doing well um is is
that people start being mean
you know you start to rise in youtube
and then there's kind of a group of
british youtubers there was a big scene
uh that sort of collapsed in on itself
uh centered around alex day
wow
he's definitely involved sure
would you mind talking us through that a
little bit
yeah so around in in 2013 2014 there was
the best thing you can describe it as a
purge
um
in the uk youtube scene
where basically
a lot of of creators
all male as far as i'm aware uh
were just kind of found to
be doing a lot of predatory things
and they were getting systematically
turfed out um and it was all
um open secrets because we knew that
there were all these creators who were
very predatory and and would be you know
sexually inappropriate with their fans
or just generally
not good people but there's not really
much you can do about it because it's
not your story to tell they can just sue
you um so all you could really do is
wait for people to come forward with
things you knew were true and then
amplify that and that was sort of the
the play uh really i remember when it
kind of first started off um a group of
us were just out out to dinner and we
very darkly
you know sort of said who's who's going
to be next and we you know chatted and
came up with a list of about
seven people and within six months all
of them were gone you'd see this again
in in sort of
a few years with the metoo movement
basically what we saw in me too it had
happened
beat by beat in the uk youtube scene and
it was just very weird um
and grim
and
i i wish more people knew about it
almost because i do worry that it's just
going to happen again now logically it
just will um that you know the the same
the same thing will just happen in the
sort of the tick-tock world where you
have a lot of
new pretty
young people getting loads of attention
suddenly and
having the opportunities to abuse that
attention and
you know
those who do not learn from history are
doomed to repeat it and all that so
i do hope it doesn't happen again i
really do
if you met someone now at a convention a
young person who's thinking about
starting a channel for the first time
what would you say to them oh i do uh
and for a while i would say don't uh
because i was really miserable that's a
miserable little
i'd be like just don't do it um
what i would oh gosh i mean the thing is
it's
it's shifted so much what it means to be
famous on the internet has changed so
much over the years that i almost
wouldn't be able to tell someone what to
expect
because
fame looks so different now
on on youtube i had such a slow steady
growth
over the course of years and even though
i did have a big boom at one point that
boom was only getting like a million
subscribers within a year
comparatively now kids are
getting a million followers on tick tock
in a week
or or so and
that's unfathomable i can't
imagine the mental
weight of that
i was at a convention last year and i
was on a panel with a bunch of other
creators and the question went around
when did you start posting videos um
and it's worth noting all of these
creators had similar numbers to me you
know followers in the millions and every
single one of them started posting the
year prior in
2020. that was just that was mad
that was and
the scariest thing about that was they
had no idea what they were talking about
um and i don't mean that to be rude but
it was just they had not had the
necessary
growth and humbling and experience that
you get uh when you have a large
audience and the
the biggest thing is responsibility um
you know you need to learn that when you
you're an influencer that term exists
for a reason and it's an appropriate
term if you tell people
what to do or what to think they will do
that they'll believe you they see you as
a authority figure so i i have to choose
which brands i work with and i choose
carefully i won't work with
like alcohol brands and i've had plenty
of alcohol brands approached me and just
offered wild amounts of money that i
would love to take but i know that my
audience is young and susceptible and
i'm not going to promote it to them if i
had an older audience say yeah no
problem but i know my audience and
therefore i know the responsibility i
have to them
even if you're a 17 year old and you
think there's no way anyone is going to
be
i have any power or responsibility
you're wrong you do there because
people your age and younger and even
older are listening to you and viewing
you as an authority figure and they
respect you and they are
taking what you say literally even if
you don't want them to
and
that is an intense responsibility
please wield it carefully
[Music]
if i started making videos where uncle
roger is saying things like oh i'm asian
i love eating dog that would be a
problem right but to the people who
accuse me of uh
that character being a racist caricature
i would say i urge them to actually
listen to the things i'm saying
and see that
everything i say is lifting our people
up